e
partie à Montréal.
Louis-Philippe Ouimet.
- T'es un bon chien!
- Benjamin, 4 ans, regarde les
aventures de la Pat Patrouille
tous les matins et il connaît
par coeur le nom de ses héros.
- Rocky, Chase...
MARIE-PIER LEFEBVRE,
mère de Benjamin
- Il capote sur "La Pat
Patrouille" depuis qu'il est
tout petit. C'est l'émission
qu'il aime le plus. Fait que
nous, on le suit là-dedans.
♪ Pat Patrouille
Pat Patrouille ♪
♪ Dès qu'il y a une embrouille ♪
- Véritable émission culte,
"La pat patrouille" a vu le jour
en 2013. Cette série canadienne
met en scène les aventures
du jeune Ryder et de ses amis
canins, dont les célèbres Chase,
Ruben et Marcus.
Après la télévision, voici
maintenant "Pat Patrouille,
le film", qui se déroule
à Aventureville, une ville
en danger.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pat Patrouille au complet
et parée à l'action, chef!
NICOLAS DELVAL, dir. de studio,
Mikros Animation Montréal
- Nos chiens préférés vont venir
sauver les citoyens de tous
les dangers qui ont été mis sur
la route par le maire Hindegger.
- M. Hindegger va détruire
Aventureville!
- L'animation du film a été
réalisée à Montréal
chez Mikros Animation.
Pendant deux ans, près de
340 employés ont participé
à un moment ou à un autre à
ce projet de plusieurs dizaines
de millions de dollars.
Pandémie oblige, une très grande
partie a été produite
en télétravail.
LAURENCE VACHER, dir. de prod.,
Mikros Animation Montréal
- On a dû être très créatifs
sur cette partie-là.
Normalement, un projet,
ça se fait en équipe, avec
une cohésion et une émulation
de groupe sur place.
Je dirais que les effets
spéciaux ont été un des plus
gros challenges du show.
Quand on lisait l'histoire,
on disait : wow, comment on va
faire ça?
- Il est temps d'embraser
le ciel!
- Pour animer ces rois
de la débrouille, certains plans
ont nécessité plusieurs mois
de travail, dont la scène
de l'explosion.
CHARLES GRANGER, superviseur,
composition, Mikros Animation
- La commande initiale
du réalisateur était d'avoir
une explosion qui n'était pas
effrayante pour les enfants.
Donc, le défi, ça a été de faire
une explosion qui est grandiose,
mais en même temps, qui n'est
pas effrayante.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Extraction moto!
- Grâce à des projets comme
"Pat Patrouille, le film",
le secteur de l'animation est
en croissance à Montréal.
Et pour ses autres projets,
Mikros Animation a tout un défi
à relever.
- On recherche, à Mikros,
près de 400 personnes qui
pourraient nous rejoindre
au cours des prochains mois.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pat Patrouille,
quel est le problème?
- En attendant de voir le film,
la mère de Benjamin ne peut
s'empêcher d'acheter des pâtes
de la Pat Patrouille!
- J'avais pas le choix.
Quand j'ai vu ça, je les ai
prises. Puis j'ai les gaufres
Eggo aussi, de la Pat
Patrouille, puis toute la...
toutes les affaires qu'on voit à
l'effigie de la Pat Patrouille,
bien, on les achète parce qu'on
veut lui faire plaisir.
- Et pour lui faire plaisir,
Benjamin ira voir "Pat
Patrouille, le film", dès sa
sortie, cette fin de semaine.
- Seulement au cinéma!
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada,